this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is supported by patreon
patrons get every episode of
playwatchlisten completely ad free early
and occasionally with extended cuts and
unedited versions if you like the show
and would like to support the podcast
head to patreon.com beautiful oh
Austin's timing wow that is good timing
did we summon him
we summoned him that's crazy
it's amazing hello hit record Austin I I
I felt a kind of parent Supernatural
songs
and then you showed up immediately
yeah it it actually kind of burns uh and
I I really I really would appreciate uh
sparing use of uh the summon spell I
apologize that's on me
um just iron a tight ship I uh cuss
Austin if he's ever late which he almost
never is to be fair I don't know why I'm
punishing you specifically and not Troy
yeah no it's it's it's uh he's stuck on
the train complex
no I know this I know this month has
been absolutely Bonkers for him and for
me too which is why I've been also I've
also been a little
um sort of crappy in my dependent my
ability to be dependent upon
um I feel like the kind of audience
we've cultivated they're just happy when
the show exists they're not mad when it
doesn't we are okay good vibes yeah not
a lot of entitlement hey listeners great
job you're doing great we're really
really proud of you I appreciate you you
make us not hate you it's really lovely
that's fancy that's the internet
that's amazing
um
did you guys see the uh Apple
um announcement Apple Vision Pro I
believe it's called
yeah I watched that whole thing through
it's a couple of hours long wasn't it oh
was it I only watched the yeah the
headset well the vision bit was right
right at the end there was like an hour
of History features writing to iPhone
first yeah yeah can I show you the
single most wonderful thing to come out
of that apple bit are you talking about
the meme you shared on your Instagram
story yes I just okay
did you message it to me yeah
the the sheer quantity of takes on that
Nicole Kidman thing is just makes me so
happy it's so amazing I had a friend do
a movie night recently and before
watching the film that we all went to
her place to watch she gave the full
Nicole Kidman AMC speeds
fully rehearsed Barbados have you seen
the Saturday Night Live uh version of it
where where it just gets like she starts
like floating and has like a like a
poltergeist voice and
it's like SNL obviously is very hit or
miss this is one of those that I was
like they they picked the exact right
thing to to go after and they did it
amazingly where it just escalates Way
Beyond sanity especially because it's
nothing inherently wrong with the that
Nicole Kidman thing it's just very
memeable
um but I did see some some quality memes
come out of the Vision Pro and like I
love VR and AR and I use VR genuinely
almost every day nobody ever believes me
it's a lot because I work out in it
um like even if I have like 15 minutes
between meetings and I want to just move
I'll play Beat saber or whatever I do it
all the time uh and so I was really
excited I was like maybe Apple are the
ones that can that can do this and some
things about it that I thought looked
absolutely incredible
um some things I found horrifying like
the idea of using FaceTime but not you
don't get to see the person who's
wearing the headset's face you instead
get an animated version of their face I
don't think anybody wants that it looks
[__] terrifying uh so it's a tricky
problem to solve right if you want you
have to have a camera you have to have a
camera but then you're looking at
someone with a blindfold on so I can see
I can see the journey you go on there if
it's just that is such a I think maybe
we just don't use that for FaceTime uh I
see a lot of like I think editing would
be really cool I actually think there
there are a lot of
ways in which writing would be very
helpful um because even with this giant
model that I have I sometimes want more
reference sheets or like things upstairs
the swordfish fantasy yeah swordfish
fantasy of like nine monitors yeah and
they're all huge
swordfish
no well any swordfish reference but I I
I just picture you with your rolled up
sleeves and your drinking wine and
you're dancing and there's like the
house music I I'm sat here and I've got
like my ultrawide monitor in the middle
and I've got like a sec two other
monitors inside and I'm like I could do
with more screen real estate like I
could do it I have a super ultra ride
monitor it's the size of two monitors
put together and I still am like okay
well I need this document up for this
and then I need like final draft up and
then I need to be able to research
things in another one and then maybe I
need like a spreadsheet to tell me time
tape like if you need a lot more
like genuinely if this thing can do
virtual desktop to the extent that I
would expect Apple to do that I'm in
like are you in for three thousand five
hundred dollars Mike I sort of am to be
on this process I was I don't know if it
was amazing if it was amazing the
[__] price point so I was like I
can't wait to get one I want to try it
isn't that apples isn't that apples move
every time uh like the iPhone was like a
grand wasn't it at launch and this is
the thing this is the thing where all
the all the takes I I just we've been
through this before with the iPhone the
iPads the watch like and we all mocked
the first iteration it was too expensive
and then second and third gem these
things always become incredible
the first one because I'm like well then
it'll be outdated in a year when they
come up with a new one but you want
people like me to get one so we make the
things that will be the things you use
or that we we are we are basically your
willing
um army of like guinea pigs see but
here's the thing Mike I know the problem
is I've probably used more AR VR than
you have I consider myself a one percent
I've used them a lot I even had a Holo
lens
um yeah and so if I won't buy in because
it's too [__] expensive how big is
that user base and there are a lot of
things about it I think are very very
it's the developers it's the developers
I mean also people who can use it as if
you can use it as a tax write-off like
if it's a business you're buying it for
a business then then that's a whole
other thing um
all the time because I'm like it's a
write-off I can I can um me too I can
there's so many times where Angela will
be like oh we should pick this up and
I'm like let me take care of this is it
video games good is it video game
related or film related or you know
everything you know even just buying
games on Steam it's all I'll I'll be
like that I might play that someday so
I'm gonna go ahead and buy it because I
like the tax write-off well I I did that
with Gollum
[Laughter]
that might be a sizable number of the
the buyers I was wondering how many
people who like me bought it to make
content out of it uh which was
definitely my intent um but so much of
the presentation again I was like
excited for the jump I was like this
looks really cool and it didn't have the
price point in the presentation and then
I found out later and I was like Jesus
but a lot of the focus is on
uh movies like being able to watch
movies and you can do that in VR already
and it's okay
um but there are some things about that
that I I'm not sure how many people that
appeals to and that I feel like a lot of
these arbr companies underestimate how
much people like the comfort of their
living room and don't usually actually
want to replace it or something on there
for whoever sat next to them as well
right right you're never going to sell
Cinema cinematic platform where you
can't like eat popcorn and make out like
there's gonna be an audience like to put
it really blogly right like that's never
gonna it definitely [__] up Netflix and
chill that is a but that's I mean that's
it's like a that's a that's a part of it
I think that stuff is very cool like I
will definitely want I would love to
watch the whole thing of like watching
Star Wars while sat in a virtual
tattooing that's cool that's like I'm
gonna I'm gonna do that but Isn't that
cool one time
like I feel like I don't know that
that's going to change the way most
people watch movies and the funny thing
about it is the time where it would have
been most useful to me was when I was
living in studio apartments when I live
in studio apartments I was in those
apartments because I couldn't afford not
to live in those apartments so how the
[__] am I gonna afford something like
this
yeah it's and that's and that's where
it's right out of Interest along are
like what
because you're right you are like core
one percent consumer kind of for this
kind of product what price point would
have been for you the kind of not what
you thought it was worth but like what
would have been the price point where
you were like okay I guess I'll buy it
like I'm it's it's like what would be
the upper end of what you would you
would be looking at for something 1500
okay so it was significantly isn't it 35
yeah yeah
I
I don't know
like I can't justify spending thirty
five hundred dollars own a car anymore
you can bring the world to you bring the
car to you yeah um no but that's that's
that's like that's am I right saying
that is that's a round where like the
the more high-end kind of VR headsets
are kind of currently placed right yeah
there's things like basic yeah about
like the
uh meta quest which I still always call
Oculus is the one that I use the most uh
it is on the cheaper side
um but it has a lot of things that I
really like about it they've just
announced the quest 3 which I was like
oh they totally knew about the Apple
product on that's why the quest 3 got
announced three days beforehandle
um which basically is smaller and
lighter and uh has better visuals um
which I've been wanting for a really
long time the reason I use it is really
because it's so portable making it
smaller and lighter is even better so
the Apple product does certainly have
the portability and I think it's like
definitely
more useful in that not only will it
likely have beat saber on Apple arcade
oh it can't Oculus bought that I forgot
Pizza
wouldn't be able to do the construction
but it might do hand tracking
because as long as you keep your hands
in the zone which you do have to for
beat saver so I could see a world but
it's got to have good good Fitness games
and a lot of people will buy into it
yeah yeah but obviously it has the
benefit of having it's kind of AR and VR
combined because you can get rid of your
entire space which I think is incredibly
cool
um but it also has work functionality
which currently the quest is for video
games and fitness like most people who
use it on a regular basis I think are
using it for Fitness my favorite app's
called Supernatural highly recommend it
um and I yeah I love it uh and I use it
all the time but that thing is three
hundred dollars
yeah
and you don't feel bad about like
especially with Fitness stuff about
sweating into it it falls off your head
it's not the end of the world this is
made of glass obviously it's going to be
pretty careful he's deviser glass
the whole of that front face is glass so
it's definitely prosumer it's definitely
I sometimes punch myself in the face
when I'm working out yeah you probably
wouldn't want to do that with a just as
a as a uh as a motivator yeah just like
get it together [__] yeah exactly
uh
I also I'm not sure Mike if you watch
the whole presentation it looks like
sometimes if someone's sitting next to
the person it like puts their eyes
is that fake there are there everybody's
got a screen yeah so it's got a video
screen so the person is not seeing you
realize
no they're seeing a 3D avatar of your
face because it uses eye tracking so
look so everything in the awesome as
well I use it which is the eye tracker
um which is also because
because of that they can obviously put
your eyes on the screen so they know
exactly where you're looking and they
know if you're blinking so they can
animate an avatar face which is
obviously based on your face yeah I'm
sure I'm sure it doesn't look photo real
I'm sure it looks like a dead-eyed
version of you but it does alleviate one
of the biggest social problems which is
people feeling weird around people
wearing these headsets especially with
cameras facing out as well it kind of
I think it's definitely like all Apple
first passes it'll appeal to people who
want to try making stuff like we've done
we've done games for two Hardware
launches two VR Hardware launches so we
did a Google Daydream project we did a
Quest 2 project and that's a fun moment
to be on VR into as a developer and to
be making those kind of first versions
of stuff but like reminds me of when I
worked on it actually intended to be
playing a video game oh yeah
oh yeah it was like it was kind of a
bucket list like no way and one of the
creators of portal cold calls you to
make an Ouya launch title you say yes no
one ever played it and the studio shut
down shortly after but still did it but
I got to run trials they're fun though
man like doing those especially with the
newer weird Hardware like getting to go
over to Google and like work on Daydream
stuff in the Google office with the
Daydream team like that level of access
you get with someone like you here as
well of these kind of weird kind of
startupy kind of consoles of course I
think because also launch titles carry a
certain amount of
um
like the console is coming so there's a
certain covering fire that the developer
is given it would seem you would know
more than I but it's certainly from my
vantage point seemed like
the creative riskiness is actually
serves the game because it's not like
the console is gonna not launch so
they're they're they're you know it's
like the sales of the game
are
it's it's the risk factor in in trying
to assess the sales are not the same as
a year later on the console yeah where
you know it's it's like you're just
assuming people are going to be buying
it just hoping to discover a bunch of
stuff and there's obviously going to be
those like reliable War chest kind of
games that are helping to kind of cover
for everybody else now theoretically
this should be true all the time but
there was there is something about
but you're also getting funding from the
hardware usually in those situations so
you so you kind of have a guaranteed Dev
but usually this is all very you know
usually and not disclosing any contracts
but like usually a platform you know
when if you're there for a launch of a
platform the platform holder is doing
some kind of funding on the project just
to incentivize you because no one knows
if that console is gonna flop or you
know take two years to get started
saying what you're saying Austin's true
but like if you're and lots of consoles
have launched historically and if it
launches with a bad first year and
you're in that first year you're kind of
screwed you know you releasing
people forget and especially Gamers
everyone who watches this will have
forgotten but like at the end of the
console life cycle when when you're
launching PS4 yes there's excitement
around PS4 in your game coming on PS4
might have a good launch but that's the
also a point in time where the PS3 has
the most ridiculous install base so you
know you can be a you can be a small
fish in a massive Pond or you can be a
small fish in a small pond and there are
benefits and it's like you get more
depressed but potentially Less sales
it used to be as well like I think this
is less of a thing now because
everyone's got smartphones but back in
the day there was also the phenomenon of
like the the hand-me-down console so the
idea that like whatever a big console
gets sold the the old console goes to a
younger sibling was always a thing so
you so when I was working on like lots
of children's games a long time ago that
was you know those would be the moments
so the PS3 launch is great let's make
some PS2 kids games because a bunch of
10 year olds are about to get there
yeah you do you do a bunch of stuff like
that but yeah the um
so there's there's there's those
Securities there's also a lot of
pressure like and also a lot of stuff
coming online late like Dev kits and
everything like you are not working with
final Hardware you don't really know
what's going to happen you don't know
what the platform's gonna emphasize
those class structures in terms of like
communication so like the big AAA
companies may have access to cooler
stuff to do with the console than you do
because you've got lower priority in
terms of disclosure
um there's just yeah it's it's a it's a
fascinating thing being there for
launches of stuff like it's a cool
process but it's different
um and it's gotten weighed over time as
well but yeah those little Plucky
consoles and platforms
I wonder if that will occur for the
Vision Pro though like they didn't
announce a lineup of games I mean there
was footage of somebody playing with a
dual sensor PS5 controller
um but I figured maybe that was
streaming uh oh there's gonna be apple
are gonna be making calls and anyone
who's been doing good AR stuff on iPhone
is going to all be up in the next couple
of weeks yeah all VR but there's not
been so much VR content on iPhone I
imagine with I imagine they'll go first
to like the AR people are already in
their ecosystem on the App Store yeah
open building apps
um and then I think as well yeah
probably they'll go to some people with
big VR projects but it doesn't strike me
that I don't think VR is a big part of
what the offering is here I think they
know that's a very hardcore thing that
will kind of come inevitably I think
they're much more likely to be
interested in those kind of AR embedded
experiences in the real world I think
that's it's very telling that they never
said VR or ar in the presentation at all
they're immersive worlds you know
they're they're going for an audience
who doesn't like acronyms like a match
VR and AR can be intimidating to it
sounds nerdy doesn't it yeah they're
trying to change your lifestyle or
whatever I mean overall I thought the
technology they're selling it like a Wii
basically they're doing the Wii thing I
thought it was Lifestyle Furniture I
mean not [__] worked well but it
wasn't three thousand dollars uh I
super impressive and mostly was like oh
my God I want to try this
um I also think the early hands-ons are
amazing I think it could be cool for
music as well
um Austin I like I don't know if if this
is a question that makes any sense but
is something like GarageBand that that
comes on Max like a feasible way for
somebody to actually produce music like
I don't know how in depth you can
actually get with it so that means that
like if it if it is then you're using
the Vision Pro and you could like just
be sliding around they've already
announced Logic for it yeah I was gonna
say logic is logic is a full-on
professional level what they call Daw
digital audio workstation
um and logic is a pretty standard
install for Max
um and like it's it's basically just the
professional version of GarageBand uh
but it's it's not it is meant to be
widely accessible like so it it's one of
those when you're going to like buy a
Mac and they have the software bundles
of do you want to have you know
Microsoft Office Suite installed and
logic is often like for another 100
bucks we'll throw it in or whatever I
don't remember like right next to iMovie
except yeah it's free
yeah it is but it is a full-on
professional piece of software I mean I
have tons of composer friends that score
major things in logic so it's it's not
it's not one of those where it's there's
any compromise to using it I'm going to
come in with a correction immediately to
save the comments section they announced
Logic for iPad not for Vision Pro that's
me blurring two things that happened in
the same press conference okay but still
if it's on iPads likely they're gonna
bring it across in any case I assume
GarageBand will because it comes with
everything um but I I like
I feel like as somebody who's always
been interested in music production but
has never tried it that doing it in that
kind of workspace appeals to me for some
reason more than any other workspace
like if I remember it turns around and I
remember doing an early test before
launch of dreams and they had a kind of
rudimentary version of a Music Garage
Band type Creator tool yeah I've seen
that and the way they kind of put it in
3D space as a way to visualize like the
the sort of the musical timeline as sort
of a thing that's physically passing
through space and you place things in
its path in order to function as plugins
like I want to add Reverb so I'm going
to make a Reverb Cloud that the note
literally goes through and I remember
thinking that was an incredible way to
visualize music for especially for folks
that may not think in terms of what is
yeah and I saw literally this morning I
didn't watch the Apple presentation but
I saw a composer this guy Simon who's
who uh who used to work for James Horner
and thus assumed the mantle of of he
scored the newest avatar for James
Cameron uh uh in light of James Horner's
death uh he wrote like I I he goes I see
myself writing I can already just
predict this is going to be how I write
music from now on like he he was
immediately sold I didn't I didn't get a
chance to unpack what specific thing he
was responding to or what part of his
workflow if he means mixing if he means
composing in its most raw state but he
was all abuzz about the potential of
this thing from a composer's point of
view and this is a guy scored Avatar so
we're talking about someone who has
obviously the highest possible
professional needs well and I feel like
if we have three creatives on this coal
and him who were going to be replacing
you with obviously Austin
um and that Mike and I both go for
writing amazing uh and a composer said
that literally for music production I
mean if you've tapped into the appeal of
like creative business people it doesn't
appeal to me for video editing
um I I don't really know why I I think
mostly because I have so many keyboard
shortcuts that I feel like it's so much
easier to keyboard oh you can use the
keyboard and mouse but that's the view
they've demoed it like you can have a
Bluetooth keyboard and mouse in the real
world in front of you you have your
MacBook I got that
you'd have MacBook you have whatever
you've got in front of you it's just
additional screens around okay well
that's great news but still I think my
monitor does everything that I need you
wanna yeah yeah maybe that's just the
scale of videos I'm editing are not like
I'm not working with that many
Clips in the timeline or whatever
um yeah I think I think it's very
interesting I don't know if this is
I might be drawing between lines they
also announced the new desktop Mac the
studio
without showing a screen connected to it
and there's a part of me that's like
well that's good uh there's a part of me
that's like I wonder if that's the
offering basically is you have your your
little mac Tower
Austin has uh replaced his background
image with a composer
in the corner
someone in the comments someone in the
comments can diagnose me but like one of
the things that I've really helps my
productivity is grabbing my laptop and
just going to a different room or
sitting outside like changes of scenery
really [__] help me yeah totally so
the idea that I could be working and
just like basically like change my
wallpaper 3D world around me while I'm
working well for video games It Feels
Like That Could genuinely help me I
think we wouldn't be allowed because
they don't let us use Apple product for
security reasons but
um I could have concept data
I could literally have a clip playing
what level design has been working on
while I'm writing a scene I could have
all of that on one screen at once or in
my living room at once and that sounds
[__] so helpful I mean I already
while I'm writing unspecified sci-fi
franchise that I'm currently writing I
will
Avatar my most recent credit
hey Simon uh what was it like working on
Avatar
uh amazing you can see I maintain a very
stoic expression on with my iPad
connected to Pro Tools and a bunch of EQ
filters wait does he have his iPad
connected to that's what's under his
hand
[Music]
no it's well maybe that's a mouse got a
mouse on an iPad which is like unhinged
we need to put you in jail for that
Simon no no this this is this is why
Simon's getting into VR yeah he's like
this I keep using my my iPad it doesn't
work
get me that I'm saying like yeah
I do so much mood stuff in terms of like
putting on music doing lighting changes
and stuff like do I like that already is
part of my my process is to like play
with my Apple it's the idea of like
doing that at another level if the
resolution's good if it's comfortable if
it's not too heavy if it if it feels
good to wear it for a few hours that
kind of thing that's the other issue is
it's got a two hour battery life but you
can plug it into the mains as well but
then you're tethered so there's if we're
riding with it there's gonna be some
interesting a lot of people would be
that's exactly um I do think that
one issue that I have with the Quest 2
which again I'm hoping the quest 3
alleviates
um
is
it gets my head gets sore after about 45
minutes and it's not uncommon for me to
work out in it for 45 minutes straight
um but it does start to hurt and I think
that's because of the way it's weighted
so I like that the Vision Pro has the
battery uh in your pocket to take that
um away but I also
[Laughter]
I was just putting in little visual
jokes for us what a great hang on can
you speak like Grant Coco though Austin
that's a tough one brushes like this
he's not because he's got he's at a
Manchester or something he thought he's
probably uh this is hard yeah I don't
know how to do it I don't know how to do
Manchester I can get someone in from
outside yeah
I'll just grab someone yeah
uh what was I saying I hope that it's
not too front heavy
um I'm sure that they've done that
Apple's very good about that [__] minion
so we'll see because the back thing it's
that front is glass and aluminum yeah
that's that's weighty but the back pad
does look very cool though I also wonder
if that will stretch over time because
that would be a major problem where the
Oculus sorry The Meta I'm calling Oculus
I don't care has um either a strap over
the top uh or mine has a strap over the
back that you like tighten with this
little circle
um and I have just an extra battery pack
sitting on there so it's like weighted
evenly it's yeah I'm a big fan
um the other thing that really blew my
mind that I'm not sure if this exists in
this capacity is in any other Hardware
is they spoke about audio Ray tracing
they mentioned the spatial spatials but
they didn't just call it 3D audio or
spatial like like laptops talk about
that they referred to it I believe the
phrase was audio Ray tracing and then
they showed an environment with audio
about like what is that what is that
something they model with the airpods
they model so when you get airpods you
take photographs of the side of your
head so they can take so they can or you
do 3D scans of the of your ears so they
can model what your ears are shaped like
so that their sound can sound oh boy
who's that smoldering
look at him baby Troy all is he in that
photo 12. he looks like so
why can't I
it's soon there's the other four members
of the boy band are also in that picture
uh what did you just say Mike
I got distracted by Troy
I mean
this that's the show oh sorry I will
take credit away from you I got uh
distracted by Austin
um what was I saying yeah
I've never [__] done that what are
you talking about
you can absolutely go into your settings
and and map the your ears so you get
better spatial audio so it sounds like
how your ears here sound yeah is that
just with the the new
I think I've got the I have not got the
newest ones I've got like a generation
yeah the new ones like
the case looks different it's got like
yeah hold up the case to you is this one
you've got
yeah yeah that's excuse me the new ones
so you can absolutely no idea that was a
thing
it's but that's that's something I was
watching a YouTuber who's done Hands-On
with this and he's like in retrospect
the fact that the last few things that
uh Apple have been announcing are small
Graphics processors spatial audio high
resolution screens how did we not see
this company like this is obviously the
technology they've been yeah
um because it doesn't seem like
something that is massively consumer
there's not that much appeal uh it's not
that there's not
um but VR has never taken off and again
I think a fundamental issue with that is
the thing that I think they've fallen
into here
um is underestimating how much people
enjoy their spaces I decorated this
office so that I like being in here I
don't want to block it out I really like
being in here
um living rooms are a huge thing I I
feel like that's a really big thing with
VR is that I could play a lot of games
in VR
um but choose not to
the Ultimo experience of this podcast no
it's Troy screaming you can use gun in a
mocap suit
this is we're using audio Ray tracing to
capture Troy is various wrestlers
um Austin don't you have to go I do yes
putting little visual jokes in the
podcast can you as the professional can
you answer a longest question about
audio Ray tracing I've never heard that
term that's why I was that's why I was
wondering if it was maybe just uh their
attempt to say 3D audio but
differentiate from gaming consoles or
whatnot who use that term
um
like that's what does that mean to this
it sounds like a buzzword to me yeah
yeah it's got that ring of like it also
sounds like in fairness it sounds like a
saviley conceived buzzword because you
can immediately kind of guess what
they're presumably after with that
um well the visual was that their
headphones that are built in do seem
very cool
um like very impressed by that in
general but it it was a visual of I
guess the headset having sort of a scan
of your living room and it would
I I guess bounce off of your pillows
like I don't know it's cool right like
they well because they are doing so
they're doing lidar scans they've got
like a three a 3D approximation of the
room you're in yeah so you know the
distances to those there is like if
things sound different obviously in a
small room versus a big space like you
could absolutely see them
um
I wonder if that's what it is maybe
that's like they're going to take it
down it's about accurately recreating
your space space like if you're if
you're if you're using it in a gym like
a high school gymnasium versus in your
living room with you know that's
carpeted these are going to sound wildly
different from one another and if
they're all amazing on the audio
counseling their Tech is phenomenal for
like when you're on call oh so good like
when you put audio canceling on it's
incredible so like they're already
playing and the more that it knows about
the environment the more that it can
create a you know an accurate model uh
uh someone was explaining to to me the
other day something I didn't realize
that voice over IP
doesn't work by transmitting your voice
in the the way that you would expect
over a phone but it's effectively
encoding it and then reconstructing it
from scratch on the other side
so that you're yeah it's which the
difference as little data as possible
basically yeah exactly and also for the
sake of latency and all that kind of
thing and I I had never realized that
it's not it's not making a recording of
your voice it's making like a model of
it basically and the fact that it can do
it so accurately but that also lets them
and let do noise cancellation and
whatnot because it can get rid of so
much signal
um and that's the machine learning stuff
that everyone's ignoring is we are about
to enter an era where you don't the idea
of data as we currently think of it of
like an image is a bunch of pixels or a
sound file is a waveform that's going
away that's not going to be how data
actually is stored it's gonna be more
like a vector file where you kind of
have the instructions so like this I
mean it's even happening now when we're
talking on video a a full screen video
of me is not being sent to the two of
you right now it's sending the portions
that are changing it's also doing what
Austin's saying where it's predicting
it's going well Mike's face kind of
looks like that you know what's cool
about that is that our our own brains do
that you know like every time that you
blink you don't notice that you see
black it's because your brain informs
what the image would be or looking in
the mirror one eye than the other have
you ever done that well also the fact
that we have a blind doesn't work yeah
you just
blind spot in the exact center of our of
our vision that our brain is everyone is
watching this if you've never done this
starting from the mirror tonight and
look at one of your eyes then look at
the other and you won't see your
eyeballs move it's because your brain is
constantly lying to you get rid of it so
we're just doing the same I actually
think like that's such a cool thing
about cameras is that so much of camera
Science is based on the human eye like
the fact that we also change how much
light we let in like it's very very cool
and I think I imagine that most of these
Zoom calls are uh we've already spoken
before about the AI assistant we have
highlighting whoever's speaking uh
they're probably also filling in frames
I mean like I'd say like a good 50 of
ghost videos on the internet of someone
not understanding how artifacting Works
compression a security camera
um
99 of ghost videos
I know a lot of them are like a person
stood behind a door and slammed it okay
we gotta account for all of those I
think your check is actually only half
of them are real ghosts the other half
are
it's like someone not understanding a
camera people sometimes nearly skeptical
enough just to do way more than half of
those are ghosts yeah
I I will say that that to your point um
about
uh the kind of it's about data existing
in a different form there's already
examples of this in my world that are
really cool in the form of virtual
instruments so if you
um like the traditional way of creating
what we call vsts virtual instruments is
you basically record an instrument one
note at a time and then when you play on
your midi keyboard it's triggering the
correct note at the correct what we call
velocity basically the loudness and all
that and then really sophisticated ones
will also record like all the Legato
transitions so they'll have like for
example my friend Tina the cellist she
has a sample Library you can buy uh
that's like branded with her name and
and photos and everything on from a
company called cine samples and there's
a Legato mode where you you play a
melody and you hear the cellos sliding
between the notes you know to be like
you know and the reason why is because
she recorded every note going to every
other note and it's insanely it takes
days of days of really boring tedium and
and so and the result is when you go to
download the library it's like you know
I don't know how long how big that
particular one is but it's many gigs
worth of wav files and all the computer
is doing is just rapidly moving around
grabbing which ones it's it's playing
back and but the future it would seem to
me is like there's a company called
sample modeling where they basically
just do an enormous amount of
algorithmic analysis and then they
recreate it from nothing and so the
footprint on your computer is next to
zero because there's no audio it's it's
a hundred percent data and like I there
the in particular whenever I need to use
saxophone I use the sample modeling
saxophones and they sound so good and
also because it's purely data there's so
much that you can control that you can't
that if the audio doesn't have that
baked in you don't you can't do it but
whereas with these you know if I want
the if I want the note to to like do
weird effects or I want it to get louder
and then soft and louder again then like
you could script a billion it's very
tedious but uh for purposes of virtual
instruments uh it is I looked at that I
remember a guy played for me in the
hallway at GDC like 10 years ago a
trumpet done with sample modeling and it
was basically indistinguishable from a
real trumpet and he was like there's no
real audio here how far off are we from
me playing you a song that is entirely
VSC I think you call it
um versus a real Orchestra and you not
being able to tell the difference oh I
mean the I mean there's tons of stuff
out there that's for for 20 years uh
been like that already and you already
can't tell the difference well no you
could you could tell the difference but
but I can tell the difference the
average difference like I was I was like
like Angela and I have been have been
replaying my 5 millionth time her first
time going through Mass Effect and like
this is 15 16 years old there's quite a
few orchestral cues in there that to me
are very much showing their age because
they're totally fake ah Kurt cope makes
another appearance second appearance of
the show
um but uh the uh like most movie
trailers like the overwhelming majority
of movie trailers are 100 fake
everything about it most TV shows like
you know what I mean like the vast
majority of stuff you're hearing is Game
of Thrones was was Game of Thrones
mostly digital in the earliest days of
the first show uh I'm pretty sure now
it's all or or a huge swap probably is
yeah but definitely the earliest days of
it absolutely yeah I mean it was always
it it took a lot of you know someone
like bear
uh had to sort of like strong arm a lot
of the TV that he's done to record live
and uh most of his is is done live even
as early as Battlestar Galactica uh
which was my favorite list he worked
with on Battlestar right it's like this
one specific performer that does all of
the wife sings on quite a lot of his
stuff including I'm pretty sure the
opening of Battlestar yeah right there's
stuff that uh that we certainly like
where AI is concerned I think the
plagiarism problem only persists um I
know that Google is currently testing
you know you Google a question and it
gives you AI generated answers um and
what that AI is doing right now is bad
uh it just pulls from the most popular
headlines
um less efficiently and somebody on
Twitter
good well it was just someone I was
talking to described it as basically
super sophisticated uh
uh predictive text like in your phone
like it's it's basically that sounds
funny explanation yeah it's it's the
super Advanced version of that yeah yeah
somebody on Twitter posted uh they
search for where to find I think like
high nox something to do with hinoxes in
in uh Zelda tears of the kingdom and it
basically just said he is what a hinox
toenail is uh because it didn't register
the information as they had written it
and then it was more useful to go to the
Articles below because the humans know
what you're going to be searching for
because they played the game uh or
otherwise it gave vague locations like
areas of the map that are not really
useful because you need such so it's
gonna say game FAQs are one of the most
optimized like search engine and that's
a human being lifestyle I know that
people are going to want this yeah
unless the AIS played the game it cannot
generate that information so it is
really still just plagiarism
um and I think that's obviously still an
issue with a lot of art too though I
have seen some really cool uses with art
again plagiarism obviously bad but I
follow a designer I don't know if we
spoke about this before on Instagram who
Jenna she's a fashion designer generates
images via uh Ai and then creates
dresses based on what they come up with
and it's [__] cool because it seems
even though it's just putting together a
bunch of human-made stuff without any
credit it's uh something that it seems
like it would be difficult for a human
mind to just come up with but fashion
designers have been using like collages
like that's true storming ideation
process for a long time for centuries
yeah so yeah
yeah there's there's value in it as a
tool as I think the the two issues I
have with here are as you say the
plagiarism aspect which I'm not sure how
you untangle that frankly at this stage
the cat's out of the bag that's that's
bad the other thing that bothers me is
just how it's oversold just it's been
it's being the the general public has
such a weird perception of what this
stuff can do in terms of how it you know
it the idea that they can originate
things they can generate you could write
a whole novel with an AI no you couldn't
not if anyone would read like it's all
it's
a tool wrote a chat GPT had it write a
Black Mirror episode and he said it was
dog [__] and they also watched a
stand-up comedian do a stand-up set that
was written by chat TPT and South Park
uh recently used it as well they had an
episode I'm pretty sure they aired it uh
uh or they're gonna I saw the headline
but I'm behind on South Park right now
but they definitely were like we're
gonna make an episode about AI written
by AI which is an incredibly South Park
thing of them to do especially if it's
bad and yeah well that's the thing like
they would they would the worse it is
the better for them yeah but by
definition an AI can't generate
something new it's it's entirely always
regurgitation yes
in the way we read it we can through
that regurgitation we can add new
meaning to it we can see new meaning and
guided by an artist I think it's
incredibly useful I I've I've looked at
it I've played with these things a
little bit and there's a brainstorming
tool or as a frankly as a clever Google
like if you have a question that would
be hard to Google because it requires so
many context clues there is value in
something like this support research
tool but it's not it's it's being it's
being uh I think frankly too much
pressure is being put on it to be like
the death of artists by the people who
are trying to build well that's because
all the questions jumped on it
AI it's the same [__] guy but there
was that story that came out which
everyone was obsessed with for 24 hours
of the the in simulations and AI had
killed an operator in a military
simulation utter nonsense never happened
it was uh it was a general basically
positive that as a theory he had of how
an AI would work in the real and that
turned through oh is that the telephone
it turned into a it was and that's the
thing is there's a credulity the great
that I saw someone say that I'm stealing
this from someone else the the greatest
thing with AI from like a marketing
point of view is they're able to lean
into hundreds of years of Science
Fiction yeah and the average consumer's
view of AI is data how
um Terminator whatever and if you play
into that image that people have in
their heads you don't really even need
to bother inventing anything you just
kind of rely on that Association
um and it's and it's it's an because
it's it's similar to the nft thing it's
like there's Cool Tech here potentially
there's cool uses for this Tech but it's
being jumped on by just the worst people
and exploited in just a bunch of gross
ways yeah because they want to make
money which is the same thing here's a
question I uh it's almost like there's
some kind of issue with the way we have
our society set up for the acquisition
capitalism I don't yeah I don't get into
it today everybody looks directly you
can always tell you can always tell Mike
is getting ready with one of his takes
when he leans into the microphone and
goes it's almost as if
money back I want to see I want to see a
hypocrite of the show I want to see a
Supercut every time
2 500 attack you piece of [__]
here's a question I'm going to
redistribute the vision prior to the
people
um the Seas the means of virtual
reproduction
um so the um
uh when you said by debts definition it
cannot create something new uh here is
my I know I'm not the first by any
stretch to Echo this which I which is in
a way meta to the very question I'm
asking but the Oculus yeah sorry Oculus
this is very Oculus yeah this is
um the given a sufficiently large data
set at what at what point does something
then
become new
for all intents and purposes because if
the data set is for example the whole of
human knowledge
where does the boundary between that and
what any other normal human artist is
doing of just drawing on the whole of
human knowledge and their own
experiences it seems like that's less of
a magic
pulling out of a black box of
indeterminacy the artist's Muse than it
is just we internalize the data set in
slightly unpredictable ways that's sort
of essentially what seems to Define what
being an artist or Creator is given a
sufficiently large data set where does
the line become where that's not really
fundamentally all the AI is doing as
well I don't understand I don't know the
answer to that to me it seems like I I
apparently I'm going to arrogantly
assume I do and give an answer which is
great intuition and understanding of the
data set is you're absolutely right like
again like something else I've read
recently that is 100 True which is which
is being being an innovator in a field
95 of the time innovators are just
people who apply a mode of thinking from
over here to over here that's most
Innovation it's just it's just stealing
an idea from one area of society or
creativity and applying it to a
different one yeah that but that
requires the person doing it to have
intentionality to go oh there's an
interesting juxtaposition here my
interest so to use me as an example I'm
interested in dinosaurs and paleontology
and I'm interested in
um trying what else am I interested Tron
so let's put dinosaurs in Tron that's
really interesting right and I can
originate that in whether or not you
think Tron dinosaurs which we're not
doing apologies Disney
um whether or not you think that's a
good idea it's an idea whereas when
you're talking about
um as you said like predictive text
essentially which is all these systems
are is there a chance it randomly mushes
together dinosaurs and Tron sure but
then what because he doesn't know what
dinosaurs are and doesn't know what Tron
are so they can't say anything
meaningful about that juxtaposition it
can't make an interesting link it can
just work out the next word that should
be in the sentence in a very boring
Progressive Way It Is essentially a very
very impressive
set of monkeys and run a typewriter but
that that's where the monkey and
typewriter thing is actually the Perfect
Analogy where if you if if it's able to
generate um million variations on Tron
plus dinosaurs it doesn't strike me as
implausible that one the point of that
metaphor has never been if you've got
enough monkeys in a room they'd be as
clever as Shakespeare that's never been
the point of that metaphor right the
metaphor is random happenstance can come
on yeah they'll accidentally happen upon
it but it was never but I always think
about what you're opposing is what is
can the machine ever kind of be as
creative as human and to my mind I know
the monkey but I don't know that it
would never write Shakespeare because if
you think of it through the lens of like
ready for voting if it made if it made
millions of things and the humanity was
kind of cutting across it and one of
them happened to stand out and by dumb
luck be interesting and got organically
sort of upvoted through a mass consumer
Not only would it have accidentally
created something people found
interesting but it then would know what
people found interesting which would
seemingly feed the data further so
that's where I go my argument would be
the creative in that situation the
community who I voted the thing yeah for
sure the meaning in it yeah absolutely
yeah oh yeah but I I'm I'm not I'm going
purely from the consumer side does this
have the potential to replace the artist
because the consumer can eventually
teach it what it wants even if it's in
an underlying philosophical sense I
don't know but it doesn't strike me it's
impossible I totally issue the thing I
totally think it can eventually replace
the artist and here's the thing about
like even writing a screenplay like you
can write a screenplay that is almost by
Design
um you can turn yourself into the AI
robot and be like let me mash this theme
in this theme and then literally follow
the beat to the hero's journey and give
me like 15 of the touchstones and then
just [__] Port that into a script
that looks like this script oh let me
pull this from the screen you can do
that yourself and it would probably sell
I think that there are a lot of
screenplays even now that are written
with like Mass Market consumption in
mind and less art in mind uh so I 100
what you just described Alana is not how
I want to be really clear and this this
stuff might to be clear it's evolving
technology so everything I say might be
wrong in two weeks
but fundamentally the Brilliance of the
marketing these people have done around
AI has been to convince the two of you
to think about it in the terms you are
which is where it's a stupid human isn't
there yet oh yeah sure that the the this
AI if you go to charge EPT and say write
me a movie screenplay it's not going to
sit down Alana as you do and go okay one
of my themes how do I plug this in
what's an idea here what my Beats I have
to hit it's just going to write the
first word of a script and the first
word of a script 99 of the time is int
and then it's going to go to the next
word and it's going to go a lot of them
are set in office it's just trying to
work out the next word in the sentence
when you say about it internalizing the
philosophy Austin of what the community
is wanting it can't it's not that I
don't think it can today and maybe not
for decades to come but it but I'm
simply hypothesizing on what's possible
within the spectrum of if as as as as
just unfathomable amounts of data is is
is harvested and ingested the patterns
emerge where you know
we're we're
predictable organisms on a on a
sufficiently zoomed out level you know
populations move with predictive uh with
predictability far more than individuals
do and if this thing is operating at
that level then it doesn't strike me as
implausible that eventually it could
create things that really are
good enough for what most people are
looking for uh you know what I mean and
that's not that's definitely think it
can I just don't yeah I think you can
make content for sure it can make
content I can't make art that's that's
the and we can have hundreds of years of
arguments about what the difference
between those two things is yeah I'd be
an idiot to say could could someone
sneak a piece of ai ai generated
paragraph past me and I wouldn't notice
of course they could like of course they
could like that's and to me that's the
value probably not yet I think it's
pretty clear from this conversation that
I've been AI generated this whole time
I've been playing this game recently uh
you can it's just a browser-based thing
I don't know if you can call it a game
um it's it's a game we have to guess if
you're talking to a human or an AI
um and you have we chat for about three
minutes and I've gotten it right every
single time every single time I go
that's an AI clearly because you can
tell motive
um sounds like the future of Chat
Roulette you're like is this an AI and
then it just shows you it's junk and
you're like that one was not yeah it was
bad but with slightly less dicks
yeah uh there was also a guy on uh
YouTube I was watching a video who
basically made an AI Instagram account
to see if like he could fool the
internet with it or whatever every part
of it was AI including everything that
she said and the only person that she
had a lengthy conversation with with
figured out that she was AI was like and
hey I wrote this this is definitely an
AI
um again that's just where we're at
right now yeah um and it's it's also
kind of hard to say like could you give
me a paragraph written by an AI and fool
me because
the problem with that is that the AI
could in theory just copy paste a
paragraph from a human and so which is
largely what it's doing so how do you
say which is AI and which is the human
just because it's delivered to you by an
AI a human still wrote it so that you're
not being fooled by the AI yeah and and
I do to be clear like I do have the same
optimism you two have that one day we we
could get there I just unfortunately I
think the methodology that's being used
for the current models is an amazing
parlor trick it's the the mechanical
term like it's a very good trick it's
the it's the old chess trick where you
sit if you if you the uh Darren Brown
did it where you sit down with 30 you
can you can sit down with 12 Chess
Masters and win half the games because
all you do is play half the Chess
Masters off against the other half it's
it's these kind of simple tricks that I
think are distracting unfortunately I
think they're very cool things freaking
love Darren
yeah it's a very it's a clever trick but
that's all it is right now and that's I
think that's the that's what I find
frustrating is because there's actually
really interesting work being done in AI
That's not as immediately impressive but
very cool and things that are really
likely to lead us towards good stuff
yeah machine the machine learning stuff
that's being done behind the scenes a
bunch of it in the kind of the The
Vision Pro to Spring in Full Circle the
way in which that is able to interpret
you pinching your fingers because it's
seen billions of people pinching their
fingers and has worked out what that
means that stuff is amazing
for what I'm pointing yeah cool
interpretive AI in that way is amazing
but it's less impressive than an article
that says you know in the future
screenplay but I still just yeah you use
the word optimistic there are ways in
which we already use AI all the time
that are very very helpful I don't know
that like this application is something
I feel optimistic about because I just
can't get over the fact that we expected
some future where robots take the shitty
jobs and the humans get to do the things
they like and why is it happening the
other way around humans like this I'm
writing and and the AI is like what if
we did the stuff you do I can go a
little Lefty for a bit we kind of did do
that like in terms of manufacturing and
industrial work for the last 30 years
machines have taken most of those jobs
I've taken a lot of those jobs in terms
of the roboticization yeah look at car
factories yeah that's true like we're
we're feeling it now because we all have
white-collar jobs but the the folks
who've been working in factories all
this time have definitely experienced I
mean that's true it's the Dangerous Ones
you know like like the truck drivers
like how do we automate that a bit
better so they don't well the
self-driving car is 10 years away alone
it's 10 years away and it's been 10
years away for 40 years now and we can't
wait so close I gotta run any second uh
any second now it's definitely 10 years
around the corner we're gonna end it
yeah
I don't I don't mean to catalyze that
but I I am sort of you you you you
bastards had an interesting conversation
I couldn't break free from and uh
imagine that I know
that means every other time you're able
to leave because we bore you yeah I was
really looking for fluff uh and um
just talked about golemen I'm also very
tempted to title the episode Tron plus
dinosaurs but I'm not gonna do that as
much as I would love it
as a uh as a preemptive uh
apologies to our editor I also realized
that I plugged in my microphone and I
had it running and going when I joined
but it was like over there and still had
a bag covering it and I was talking for
the first like five minutes so the zoom
audio or whatever is going to be far
more reliable because it's going to
basically sound like a person inside one
of these and it's her feet only at this
point in the video if you could have
just been zooming in on the law on this
face for the last like 10 seconds of
Austin talking there while I was
disappointed yeah I want to give notes I
know you've already got enough to deal
with with the audio problem mostly story
about but if you just do that slow Zoom
online space we really appreciate you
jack sorry I do have the audio recording
though so we're okay
um thanks for watching everybody I'm
Elaine pierce my video again Reddit
that's my goodness video game director
and that's awesome wintry he's video
game composer sorry Simon Simon Franklin
Simon Franklin apologies who is a avatar
composer and we will see you guys next
time
[Music]
foreign